Pro wizard Narayana think he did very
well in the banker bloods cup right that
was not a different Mariana and I think
it was the probe wizard so we're playing
a three minute game I'm gonna play like
Khurana did against me albeit quite
unsuccessfully maybe I have some
improvements
you
okay let me just go for four c6 ya h3
this is the same position that I had
against against Khurana but I actually
went Queen B 3 RI in clutch chest I went
for Queen c2 with them in in the chess
table masters I went for Queen okay so I
guess I should go g6 try and try and
learn from what Fabiano did against me
and he goes a4 okay I guess I'm gonna go
any fine that's what I did as well but
with the Queen on on b3 instead and then
I could go Queen a3 and some lines
trying to offer the exchange of Queen's
rook b1 I guess quite logical okay so
clearly a lot of hot action is gonna
take place on the Queen side here so I'm
just bringing some of my forces over
there
you
but obviously rook b8 doesn't make a
whole lot of sense unless my opponent's
gonna go before at some point but I
assume he is
so this is what Fabiano did against me
just rerouting this Knight to d6 the
good thing about the d6 square is that
from d6 tonight just firmly defense
defense b7 and also prepares the
prepares the exchange of bishops which
is I think almost always going to be
positionally desirable for me although
in all this talk of positionally
desirable i am i did miss queen c3 which
is a little bit awkward for me to meet
but i think it's all good queen d8
protects protects the pawn now I'm gonna
take on b4 take on c5 it takes for the
Queen and now let's just double those
works
should I be if I went while I have the
chance no yeah I think so now I should
put the Queen somewhere or should I go
for there
okay let me go to k7 I was considering
Queen yet but I think rook a 7 a better
purpose of that movies just to go
Knights see for next preventing the
potential fork with 97 my opponents is
playing really well here he could have
gone 93 to simplify didn't do that so
I'm gonna go clean ahead finally tryna
keep some of that tension or efore
that's interesting
I'm going to take it Queen C 3
[Music]
yeah I don't know what to do go to
professor please stepping out of that of
that diagonal no I just I just take this
and hope for the best
take a four and I always got some rook
a3 moves also some Queen eight five
maybe now I think create five
come g7 but I'm sure I'm short of time
my position is good but I'm really
getting short of time
that's an annoying move it's really
annoying move oh I thought it was going
to go between c3
how do I keep any pawns here
no I don't have time for this I don't
have time
Quincy 3 I was a little bit helpful now
our positions is good probably also
exchanged then it's all about speed
it tries to keep the tension 94 push
push push to pay for almost certainly
coming next
oh there we go that was a stupid dream
of he was he was thinking I was gonna go
Quinn deform but Quinn j5i was mating in
a few moves there but not sure I would
have made it in time if you just managed
to come up with one surprise but that
was tough yeah I was a very good player
Mariana very very tricky